america's
lost its culture because here's
america's problem
the world says you want to come to our
country
you can come but it's on our rules you
don't like it don't come here
but america says you don't want to come
to our country
what do we need to do to make you happy
so you stay here
because we want to make sure you're
happy adam because god forbid if you're
not happy
you may leave us rather than we're the
greatest country in the world you don't
want to be here
don't come here this is what we stand
for you go to the yankees
and a derek jeter on a rod says yeah i
don't want to get a haircut i want to
have long hair oh yeah yeah
go to the red sox just the yankees you
don't say
well let us accommodate you because we
don't want to offend you jeter and a-rod
because you're bigger than what the
yankees are no america is bigger than
any immigrant
including myself or anybody else that's
coming here but america keeps trying to
say no
you know what he just said you don't
like it
you know what we're going to do to your
heads he just fly and i'm not saying
that's the approach to take
all i'm saying is america's lost its
culture because it's trying to please
everybody thoughts no i agree and um so
there's this alignment and i try to
explain it to people and
some people get it there's an alignment
between what uh
china is and what um this idea that's
grown up in academia this
critical race theory which is really
about creating different classes of
people
really tribalism and so um you know
we're
in a lot of ways the way that the
chinese communist party looks at the
world and the way
that this um this um
divisive kind of marxist ideology is
it's it's
it's pervasive and so when when when the
soviet union was
doing its thing they wanted to make
everybody the soviet union
the chinese communist party doesn't want
to make everybody the communist party
they want to take advantage
of our own social division exactly what
you're
and then begin to push the same kind of
system so
what's happening here is there has been
a slow
effort to marginalize politically
marginalize
a whole class of people in our country
like they're not they're not worthy of
having uh representation in washington
dc or even in the state capitals
and that is what the chinese communist
party does not everybody can join the
party
right the the chinese communist party
makes sure that
you know they have you know extreme
loyalty in their members
and they make sure that you know
everything there's two constitutions
chinese communist party constitution and
the people's republic of china
constitution
the lead the sovereign the law in china
is a chinese communist party
constitution
that's a system where one party rules
and
and it makes the rules for everybody so
rule of law
like here's justice is blind right you
get a fair shot
in court in china the chinese communist
party
makes the rules so it's rule by law it's
whatever we say
goes what is happening in this country
is the same kind of effect we're we are
migrating
slowly to a single party now now that
single party establishments
includes elements of left and the right
and they basically
showed themselves uh during the four
years of the trump administration
and and even today if you talk about
election uh voting rules or you know
to the 2020 election say hey there's a
problem with the 20 even if you just say
hey there's i think there's a problem
with the 2020 election you are somebody
that's to be marginalized and that is
the thing that scares me so much i mean
we're seeing elements i'm seeing
elements
of how the chinese communist party took
over china
and and kicked the other party the
nationalist party which fled to taiwan
kicked them out i'm seeing elements of
how they won their civil war
in our society today and it's been
exacerbated by china because they
what they want is governments around the
world that look like them
they don't have to be them they just
have to look like them so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye